the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay most everyone's here we're still
gonna take a few minutes to wait for the
last on few people to show up I don't
have a ton of announcements but if you
looked at the syllabus you might notice
that there are a couple days where we
have I think we've got TBD as the topic
like to be determined what I'd like to
do is just take a quick poll from you
all or is there anything that you are
interested in learning about in the
creation of video games that you are
either we haven't talked about it in
class yet maybe we've talked about it
but not fully you've looked at the
syllabus and it's not there on the
syllabus any specific and it and/or it's
something that you think is gonna be
directly useful for the games that
you're working on right now so just
putting that out there if there are any
topics you might want to talk about
learn about let me know yes okay so yep
cool so what people do in the industry
cool you are in luck on December 1st and
3rd on the first we're having a business
and games panel so to two independent
developers in the area are gonna come by
and talk about how they started their
companies what do they do
what's their daily life things like that
and then another one following that is
the community manager for fire hose
games
Sean Baptiste is going to talk to us
about how does he get how do they get
their games out in the world and how
they get people to play their games and
how do they engage their their their fan
base and either how do they even just
create a fan base in general so that's
not on the syllabus but that will be we
will be doing that any other topics
okay I'll ask this again in a couple
weeks I'm in case something pops up
because you probably haven't done a lot
of technical things with your with your
game engines yet so if there's anything
gaming specific that you might want to
know about either let us know through
the mail through the video game bosses
email address or let us know what class
yeah I can get people so I can I can get
people who are local
we've got connections to local industry
we've got connections to the people who
make the tools in some cases depending
on the tool that's kind of why I'm
asking now cuz it gives me time to find
new to fill new gaps also it might be
something that we can talk to so if
there's anything design related that you
think is useful for your for your games
that we haven't talked about yet and you
don't see it on the schedule let us know
if there's anything technical related
jus can can can come up and say
something the other thing we can do is
if there's anything that you want to do
or if you want to set up office hours in
class to talk about a certain topic for
your your um for your game specifically
technical issues technical questions
that's what drew is here for to come and
talk to you to talk with your group as a
whole or just individual members of your
group to talk about the issues that you
have so we can do that during class
during our scheduled one and a half to
two hour on working class periods or you
can set up work office hours with him
okay I'm just give people a couple more
minutes the attendance sheet is moving
around so is everybody sitting with
their teams right now does it look like
we just share I'm gonna go across and
just kind of try to figure out which of
these teams are this is the snap team is
everyone here - okay which team this is
forecast based futures over here right
how far do you go I John to you and this
team or you in the next team cool
alright next team over which team are
you Colorado no you're a cholera team
were you the islands group animal
crossing one cool and then in the front
here we've got heatwave and in the back
it's the other cholera group
okay um I did not get a chance to play
your game so but I will eventually I'm
cool so there's gonna be a little bit of
an hour to interactivity in the talk
I've given this talk before I rewrote
the lectures and I haven't given it
since I rewrote the lecture so we'll see
how it goes
they're my backup to let me know if I
forgot anything there will be some
reading on this that I'm gonna put into
stellar so if you are interested in the
topic if you're if you have more
interest in the topic and you want to
read the reading I'm a highly recommend
it especially if you think you're going
to be in a leadership position in the
future or any kind of managerial
position or you're interested in just
psychology and how people talk to each
other and work together so our three
main topics this would actually be
pretty quick on this lecture we're gonna
talk about we're gonna do a really quick
review of agile we're gonna talk about
team dynamics and then we're gonna talk
about how do distributed agile teams
perform so what are some of the best
practices they have for performing and
then you're gonna work in class you'll
have at least two hours to work in class
today it's not a little bit more than
that so agile processes if you forget
everything in this class you end the
class you got into the into the real
world you and somebody asks you what is
agile I hope you remember this part um
iterate development is anybody doing
does anybody consider what they're doing
iterative development on their projects
right now are you working in short
periods of time so you've broken up your
time into small sprints are you doing
all you can't really read it that well
in the slide but are you within that
short period of time designing what
you're gonna work on planning how how
it's gonna work
doing it and then testing it evaluating
the test and changing are you doing all
of that within one week or two week
cycle
raise your hands yeah raise your so yes
raise your hands no raise your hands
it's okay if you say no okay if you if
you're doing something that looks like
this then great and as remember on agile
and particular scrum processes they're
based on these three pillars that um
that Sarah talked about and we first
brought this up so the pillar of
transparency
and when we mean by transparency there
really just mean a common nomenclature I
to be honest I don't care what you call
the things that you that you that you
use as part of your process in your in
your team so long as everyone even
within the team knows what it is some so
long as whoever you're submitting those
those processes to also know what know
who it is
so we're not acting as your product
owners in the class but if you had a
product owner they should also know what
you're calling things what you're
calling your product backlog what you're
calling a task how you're estimating and
how you're doing your processes so
everyone on the team should know it not
just in a more traditional manner a
project manager knowing what all the
processes are there's a number of
inspection that's going on so through
the process you are taking a look at all
the artifacts you created so those
backlog items tasks lists things like
that that you're creating during the
process you're inspecting it you're
particularly inspecting it during
meetings so you're taking a look at what
you've done in a meeting and talking
about it so you're not just doing a
process you're doing a process and
you're talking about it and you're
actively thinking about the process and
then you're adapting so based on
evidence based on needs changes and
needs you are changing that process
again if you're doing any one of these
three things you're doing process as
well and you're doing agile you're
you're doing some form of agile like
process well that's another thing I hope
you hope you take from the class the
agile manifesto and it's kind of a it is
a manifesto it is an idea it is a it is
something less in political weight
behind it is saying this is the way to
do things this is the right way to do
things but it's actually more vague than
that
it's really just saying here are some
four key things that we feel are more
important than other four key things and
today we're gonna focus so the first the
first item is individuals and
interactions over processes and tools so
we've been talking to you a lot about
process and tools for the first part of
the semester now we're going to talk
about individuals and interactions
between individuals so your team members
all right what's a team anybody give me
a working definition for what you'd call
a team
what you say a bunch of puppies is it a
group of people is it just a group of
people anything else so it's a
collection of individuals so it's a
group of people they're working toward a
common purpose they have shared
responsibility for common outcomes if
one of those puppies trips that stick
goes in another puppy's mouth and it
hurts a lot so I want you to keep that
in mind
shared responsibility common purpose
common outcomes
alright so teams evolve over time and
the the little bit of research I'm going
to talk about it actually comes from
studying group behaviors but in the and
this is all from about the 1960s and on
up and around the 2000s and I'll post
this reading up it was proven or was
there was some studies shown that it
this actually works for teams this does
work for for people who have a common
goal but as you get a bunch of people
together and get a small group of people
together and in our terms we're talking
a small group of people eight to ten
people maybe a little bit bigger but
about ten people total they're gonna
evolve based on those interpersonal
relationships so how they know each
other what they talked about how they
talked about and their task behaviors so
we're gonna be talking about not the
tasks that are do you are doing in your
teams but the behaviors surrounding the
tasks that you're doing it so if you are
working on a task if you are doing some
coding how are you
coding or who are you coding with how
are you talking to other people about
what you're coding and you can apply
that to any other tab any any task that
you're doing in your teams there's a lot
of different theories actually Wikipedia
is a pretty good I'm just a good
nutshell of what are all the different
kinds of theories and how different kind
of models we can use to describe how
groups talk to each other and how groups
evolve but they all come down to these
common things there's a period of
getting to know each other there's a
period of experiencing conflict and
there's both positive and negative
conflict when you're talking with each
other your roles shift based on changing
knowledge and changing experience and
hopefully at some point there's some
kind of consensus there's some kind of
moving forward decisions happen here the
point is though what kind of decisions
get made are they effective decisions or
they ineffective unproven they get made
because you just have to make them and
you have to move on and we're hoping is
that by analyzing how your team's work
you can then move towards having some
effective decision decision-making so
one so the model that we're going to
talk about is Tuckman's model from 65
it's got four phases forming norming
storming performing it's very cutesy you
get its gets used in training sessions a
lot it can just be something that you
can just spit out and say and someone
says oh you're smart you know that that
that model but maybe you don't know
everything behind it I might be more in
the you're smart but maybe you don't
know more everything behind it I'm still
learning about how all this works but
each phase has items you can identify
I'm more useful for us is this is a
model you can use to figure out where
your team is right now what phase are
you in so you can then make decisions
about where you need to go and how you
need to work together better so the
forming phase of it which is when you
first start getting together everyone
wants to be friendly everyone wants to
get along to be accepted with each other
there might be some serious problems
from the get-go but they're usually
avoided and the team learns about
challenges and goals but not much gets
done there's no real task completion
going on in this stage has that
everybody's seen this that can when you
think about your previous teams you've
been in the stage right when you first
got together said project to project
three I'm gonna talk I want to ask you
some questions about project two and
three as we go forward alright that's a
happy stage then storming happens people
are able to express discontent there
actually might have been discontent in
phase one but it actually wasn't being
it wasn't being expressed in some form
and phase two it's being expressed but
how it's being expressed can be kind of
different so it could be someone
actively saying no you're wrong that's
stupid
it could be someone not talking but
they're feeling the same thing and
they're thinking about the same thing
it's the same kind of biscuit
can happen opinions tend to get
challenged um it can be contentious it
can begin Pleasant in order to advance
past this stage what your team really
needs is tolerance and patience I just
can't get through it but even more
important you need to establish lines of
trust and open communication to get
through the stage and this is why this
is what we've been doing for the past
first of the semester is creating
processes we've been giving you some
tools that you can use then you can then
create those processes in your teams so
just a quick hand raise from teams does
anybody think that they are in this
stage right now do you think in your
team you are currently you're expressing
discontent you are creating processes
you don't have processes yet but you're
figuring out what your processes might
be maybe what do you say you're not sure
okay
all right next step norming so this is
where you have those processes
individuals start giving up their own
ideas and goals you're moving you're
actually moving towards a team goal
right now and people are starting to
take responsibility and rules are
established ok compare the storming to
norming raise your hands if you think
you're in Norman your team is a norming
right now ok yeah all right now raise
your hands if you think your team is in
storming right now ok
all right so is anybody performing are
you functioning as Ian and efficiently
are your team members already autonomous
is descent expected and addressed right
now this is where you want to get to you
probably aren't this far yet my bets are
probably somewhere in the in the
storming area things may be getting
close to the norming area things
basically you're still trying that
you're still talking to each other
you're still trying to figure out what
are the the different ways of
communicating with each other what are
the the different processes and rules
you might have and you might not get
this far in class in class by the end of
the semester you might not be fully
efficient by the end of the end of the
class and that's okay
but if you are it's kind of cool so um
the model and practice tends to be it's
nonlinear it's it gets talked about and
it was originally established as a you
go from here to here to here to here you
go through the phases at the end of the
thing you're done your team's awesome go
you we actually see in process is that
teams tend to they get in the forming
they go in the circle where they go from
from having some issues figuring out how
to how to deal with those issues
establish some rules all right we're
doing really well again new challenge
comes up we're back into we're back in
the storming where we are we've put
ourselves in a position where we don't
know how to talk to each other or we
don't know how to communicate with each
other so there's some problems with them
with the model this is really a a
descriptive model it's a way it's a tool
for us to use to see how things are
going it's basically a way to evaluate
symptoms but there's no triggers in the
model we don't know when those things
happen when does it when does your team
switch from storming to norming so this
is what I'd like to you to do when
you're in your teams just take a couple
minutes talk about talk about your
previous teams you've been on talk about
the team you're on now when do you think
your team would move from stage this age
and how could a team move intentionally
so and in particularly think about that
storming to norming part of it so what
is it going to take for your team right
now or what happened in your team right
now to go from we are having some
talking with each other where we have a
bunch of opinions - we're all on the
same page take three minutes just just
one thing I want to chime in it's a very
very good chance that your team actually
is still in forming stage and one of the
reasons why no one like a very few of
you might have put up your hands that
you don't actually want to express
dissent which is exactly the situation
then you get in a forming stage you know
it's it is uncomfortable but hopefully
there you can logically see the benefits
of being in a team where you can talk
about the things that you disagree with
right so so it's possible that you are
still informing and you know it's good
to identify your teeth that's okay this
is normal if evolution of a team and
that's where team is that right now so
talk about it among a team
so take three minutes just talk new
teams and I'm gonna ask you some
questions when we're done
okay so each group give me a something
you talked about about what are those
what are the triggers what are the
things you saw as he moved just let me
know which phases you're talking about
so go ahead
okay
how do you know what's that what caused
that what caused you to get there do you
think
all right so the big decisions how big
are those two teams four and four okay
so somebody else next a trigger that you
saw that that made you go from one stage
to the other do you think that the task
of solidifying gamma-d is helping you
because there's this big decision you
have to make is that helping you move
luck work as a team it's not getting in
your way
but I see that we're doing much better
job understanding each other and we see
how business with a okay cool 16 a
triggering moment that you saw in this
team or previous teams it's reducing the
number of opinions are you really right
when I was sure with your people
that's like okay all right that's a big
one that's a that's a huge difficulty
with um with student projects you've got
all these other things going on around
you do you think you need everyone to
contribute to the design or do you need
everyone to be on board with the design
having deep discussions about the
designs of the game but getting
everyone's to both be aware and willing
to participate okay because yeah there's
there's important conversations being
done that if they're not there when it
happens they're not gonna know where the
status of the game is if they're not
there okay cool thank you for that lead
because that gets us to our next stage
so we're talking like we're talking kind
of I think we find ourselves talking a
lot about the the product that we're
making is just easier it's the thing
it's that it's that hard evidence like
that hard thing you can see like it's
being made it's being done it's we can
play it it means we're probably doing
something right but it's still very
difficult to still to talk about the
people I'm although I saw being talking
with the people a little bit here
especially with accountability and in
this one it was good cool
so that gets brings you the next topic
teams are composed of individuals and
each person on your team is gonna have a
lot of different factors affecting what
they do how they do it when they do it I
can't give you the magic formula to get
them motivated what I can do is show you
some of the different ways you can then
try to either understand the people
you're with understand the people on
your team or tour find things to talk to
them about you might notice a number of
these things so to get someone who's
motivated someone who's going to be able
to participate think about all these
things think about personal development
so you're in a class you were here
hopefully because you want to learn um
you want to learn a new skill you want
to try a new skill everyone wants to
learn a new skill there might be a skill
that they want to work on on your team
and I think we've talked about that in
the past when we're talking about the
vision statement and people putting down
why they're involved on the team and why
they're involved in this project so
being aware of that and constantly
coming back to that for each person
especially if you if you have someone in
who's who is just not participating and
you need to figure out how to engage
them think about the skills that they
want to bring to the table those skills
are trying to practice I when it comes
to motivation
it largely comes down to intrinsic or
extrinsic on the extrinsic might be the
grade they're gonna get but it's really
difficult to so really hone in on that
because the grades shared which when you
group so that might be not be the place
to look at try to take a look at the in
string six things what are the things
that if they were enthusiasm food if
they had enthusiasms about the project
at some point try to remember what that
was asked somebody else on you team what
what that might have been see if you can
bring those in that enthusiasm back into
the project morale or self-worth on
there's been some research that shows
that the reason why people work well on
teams and the reason why we want to work
on teams is because it brings self it
brings us self-worth there is and in
particular there's some self-awareness
that can happen by being on a team and
getting and actually kind of links a
little bit to extrinsic rewards by
getting rewarded getting feedback on my
performance is going to help me do
better
um empowerment getting ownership so
raise your hands if your team uses
assigning tasks or taking task so
assigning tasks to raise your hand if
your team assigns tasks to individuals
that team kinda yeah you assigned so
there's one person on your team that
says you are going to do this all right
has anybody tried ownership where
someone takes a task from a set of tasks
that are available
little-little when does that work when
is ownership work what's that
so there's there some there's some of
those other things that there's some
enthusiasm for it over it yeah
okay cool so yeah yeah yep absolutely
okay so where does on yeah go ahead
absolutely so there's some okay say so
at the beginning I'm everybody takes on
tasks and at the end when you have the
leftovers um they get assigned yeah man
so it might not yet so you might
actually have ownership it might look
like you had ownership there is the
evidence of ownership in that someone
said okay I'll take that task but
there's no there's no follow-through
there's no commitment and that gets to
the next one commitment the best way to
have commitment on your team is for one
person to be committed to express that
commitment to express that loyalty for
everyone else to see that loyalty and
see that commitment and then hopefully
they pick up the ball and they're like
okay I'm gonna be committed to if that
second person doesn't do that pick it up
then the chain it doesn't travel through
the chain it just doesn't happen even
though that one person went out of the
way to show that kind of sacrifice it
just didn't get picked up um so maybe
think about is that you do you see that
chain happening on your her on your
teams do you see it breaking can you
identify where that breaking point is
and can you think about ways to fix that
trust is a big one how many so raise
your hands if you have worked with the
majority of the people on your team
before in some fashion this class or
other classes you you feel like you know
your teammates like raise your hands if
you feel like you really know your
teammates you've worked with them before
high if you really think though so one
two maybe one two three so think about
how well you know each other think about
ways you can figure out how you can know
each other better
social interactions going out to coffee
going out for lunch things like that is
there something that you can do that
will help that kind of that kind of
thing happen and then here's the big one
this is the Mighty One stress and stress
tends to be the the negative it can be
positive in that it's the end of the
project and it's due and you just need
to get things done and that can be
definitely the crunch but then there's
also the huge negative aspect of stress
and it's very that's very much an
external factor for the most part it
could be an internal factor if stress
isn't if there's some interesting caused
by internal things going on with your
team it's likely related to one of the
ones above it seriously one way to think
about these these three one two three
seven things
you can think of them as in terms of the
desirability to learn new skills or the
desired ability to take on a task so if
you're trying to come up with strategies
with your team on how to how to solve
some of these problems think of it in
those two terms all right so how do
distributed teams perform so what do I
mean by distributed what is a
distributed team yeah yeah or just
everyone's all over the place it could
mean that you are in Singapore and
someone else is in Ohio you could be
separated by time zones by oceans by and
really I think that might be East Campus
and McGregor maybe it could just be
through distance it could be through
your schools it could be through your
departments your majors whatnot there's
some kind of boundaries going on between
people in this case it slightly it's
largely time it's basically some people
can work during some hours some people
can't can't work during those hour those
other hours so what have you done so far
to to fix that they think back on some
of the post-mortems you've given us what
are some of the strategies you've
already used and seen used to to figure
out how to work in in across different
time time periods yeah
what's the call it's like what what's
that yay cool anybody else using group I
am or an IRC chat yeah cool cool okay
it's great when I have wait wait I can
hook up to things and works with your
workflow it's also just great to have
this period if you don't use any of
those maybe you think about Skype any
other things people use yeah
so reporting I remember some people had
issues with email on previous teams is
anybody still using email as a primary
means of communication on your team
how's it working for y'all so far yeah
yep
are those emails gonna be archived and
viewable by everyone at a later date
yeah I think that's why we tend to think
about um group im's and in particularly
I'm Philipp likes IRC for that very
reason certain IRC servers will keep an
archive for you um other kinds of group
where we'll do that too but they tend to
be pricey is anybody still using has
anybody started using Trello on your
teams yet yeah are using it as a
communication method or as a recording
of things okay anybody using that as a
communication method at all trying that
out okay cuz I think it can do email
notifications and things like that when
things change assigning members to tasks
stuff like that cool alright so again we
got talking into tools what other things
can we do so um another another paper
that it's gonna be on stellar if you
want to look at it was basically a
survey of distributed teams using agile
processes and giving up some best
practices of what works best for them
and I was nice and I'm just giving you
the summary of that so one thing they
noticed is having a one team mindset was
the thing that got them through working
together as a group what do we mean by
one team that the group identifies well
first identifies as a team like what we
talked about before they all have a goal
that they're going towards they all
identify as going towards that goal they
don't identify as just a as an
individual group but that's that's
actually a major part of their identity
and for them it's because that's their
40 our 80 our 120 hour work days or work
weeks something I think you you're gonna
have an issue with because you're only
because you're working smaller periods
of time but what they're able to do the
way they're able to do that is they've
got these frequent team interactions and
actually when they're working for a long
period of time they're there there are
people who are working on their own in
their home or their home office with
another team that's that's very far away
and yet these these teams still do a
daily standup
does anybody here do a daily stand-up on
their on their teams right now
so what they're doing is they're going
on video they're talking to each other
for a very short period of time about
what they've done what they're going to
do what's in their way the cool thing
with daily stand-ups and why they think
this works for them there's it goes back
to those those seven items I listed
about how do you get people engaged on a
team
it shows commitment the fact that there
are some people that there are people
who are showing up to meetings there is
some kind of personal sacrifice some
people are meeting at a very strange
hour of the day that they're not
normally going to meet and they're doing
that because of the team they're
sacrificing something personal for the
team everyone else on the team sees that
they see that kind of commitment they
feel they feel like they need to reflect
that back themselves also trust and in
this particular case it's the trust of
not letting meetings take too long these
daily stand-ups really should only take
10 minutes an effective team can do it
in five effective 10-person team thirty
seconds each go everyone says what
they've done everyone sees each other's
faces the great thing about seeing each
other's faces you can see what stage of
fear and anxiety they're in then you can
then talk to them later
and have some other personal
interactions with them the other thing
they do is they they do co-located work
they've got money some time so they're
flying people back and forth but again
they're also doing co-located work by
doing things using having Skype always
on in the background while they're
working together but they're not doing
it the entire time they can't afford
that
so one thing you can do is to schedule
your co-located time at the beginning of
the project which is just basically what
we've been doing in class
for the past few weeks at identifying
important milestones and making sure
you've scheduled a co-located period
during that milestone right before that
milestone is going to help you greatly
doing constrict teams and doing video
chat and he was a big one we haven't
talked about in class so much but I get
the impression that somebody might be
interested in this kind of thing having
coaches so we've already said we were
already seeing some of the teams have a
dedicated scrum master or a producer
think about having a dedicated coach so
someone who's on your team who is there
to cultivate team spirit they're gonna
emphasize the importance of one team
they could be your scrum master a
producer but they don't actually should
then they're not actually the same role
the scrum master or the producer is
measuring productivity they're measuring
tasks how well things get done the coach
is a very different they're looking at
how people interact with each other how
people talk to each other how people
work with each other
oftentimes people who are naturally
inclined to do one can be inclined to do
the other but that's not always the case
um so if you have someone on your team
who is one of those extroverted outgoing
or even introverted but really
interested in what individuals do
one-on-one and how individuals work see
if you can incorporate some coaching
strategies with with your teammates and
again you can do one-on-one meetings and
we can talk about this in the future if
you're interested in this kind of stuff
we can open unpack on this topic and
talk about it further but I highly
recommend it
alright so I didn't mention meetings you
do have agile meetings these people have
a jille meetings these are what they are
hopefully you're doing so who has a
formal sprint process where you plan
your sprint before you start so you
create a task you basically you create
your sprint task list at a meeting is
everyone there that's when you're saying
not everyone's there
okay okay cool I mean you had a meeting
to do to create that okay so then you
have your daily stand-ups at the end of
the Sprint's you want to have a sprint
review which is basically the inverse of
the sprint planning meeting you go back
and see what you made hopefully you have
a build and you just basically look at
the build compare the build to the
completed tasks and make sure it matches
the other meaning that you may or may
not be doing is the agile retrospective
and that's how did you work this week
does anybody doing that is anybody at
the end of their sprint talking about
basically talking about the processes of
what you did and how you did it okay
that's kind of what I expect I think
you're doing yourself a disservice if
you're not doing that and it
particularly if you are doing that and
you're making that a face-to-face
meeting that's the time when you can
talk about some of these interpersonal
issues that's the time when you can talk
about your feelings that's the time when
you can can open up and and try to
figure out what is about like why are
some of these tasks not getting on taken
on who's not doing them and what's in
their way off from doing them but really
it's not it's not about the it's not
really about what's in their way it's
difficult to talk about it about what's
in their way but it might be about what
outside of the project and outside of
the team could be in their way and you
can can work through some of those kind
of issues so I'm done what I'd like you
to do before you go and work in your
team's is schedule a sprint
retrospective so think it look take a
look at your sprint at your sprint
process how long is your sprint is it
one week or two weeks we've been
assuming it's a one week's week process
one week Sprint's schedule a time period
that everyone can attend and a time a an
amount of time that they can attend that
they can see each other face to face but
not necessarily are in the same room if
they can be in the same room awesome if
you can't try to figure out a time that
you can chat using Google hangout or
some other kind of video chat some other
kind of face-to-face video chat make
sure the meeting is focused on talking
about your processes so don't talk about
your game don't talk about the work that
done talk about how you organize
yourself on a particular talk about your
interpersonal manners talk about
basically communicate about
communicating so talk about how you are
talking to each other and yeah I'm gonna
talk to you about this again in a couple
weeks and in a couple weeks I'm to give
you some more once you're actually in
the process of I think most to you right
now are probably in the concepting phase
pre-production phase right now you're
still kind of figuring out your game you
haven't quite like I guess you got you
guys are actually working to be back in
because someone did the initial design
for you
the rest are probably still working out
that design phase when I talk about this
game again you'll likely be in full-on
production mode and so some of the the
activities I'm gonna show you might
hopefully help when you're doing these
meetings any questions okay so it's 150
go ahead and take a few minutes to break
and then the rest of the class is yours
to work in your team's but still do this